- Hello, everyone.
And welcome to the talk
by Dr. Leslie Gross-Wyrtzen.
She is a postdoctoral associate
with the Council on African Studies
and Teaching Fellow
at the Center for Race, Indigeneity
and Transnational Migration, at Yale.
She will be talking today
about Outsourcing Otherness,
with Race and Belonging
in the Morocco EU-Border.
So, the way the seminar
is gonna be organized,
so, first
Leslie is going to
sort of introduce the topics and discuss
her presentation
and then she will take questions
after her presentation.
If you could, please...
You can send the questions on a chat,
or just raise your hand
and then we'll make sure
that Leslie replies to you.
Make sure you introduce
yourself and say who you are.
She just sent a chat as well,
if you want to have a few words.
Okay,
(paper rustling)
so I think Leslie, if you want to start.
- All right, can everyone hear me?
Thumbs up.
Okay, wonderful.
All right.
(book thudding)
Well, thank you very much,
Teresa, for this invitation
to speak to you all today and to be here
with the Program for
Refugees, Forced Displacement
and Transnational...
I'm sorry, and Humanitarian Response.
And Tarana, too, who's doing a lot of
the back at the house work, right now.
You know, facilitating,
she'll help facilitate your questions
and let people into the room.
In general, I just am grateful to be here
at the MacMillan Center
that houses this program,
as well as the Councils on African Studies
and Middle East Studies,
which has been just a wonderful place
to think about migration
and border enforcement.
And thank you to those of
you who are here today.
I just wanna welcome you and
encourage you to use the chat,
to introduce yourselves, to
say what brought you here,
to, you know, pose questions,
or ask questions of each other
as well as me.
And after I talk for a little
bit, we'll have some time,
hopefully for, not just
question and answer,
but for kind of a more
collective discussion
because I think a lot
of people are bringing
all kinds of professional and
personal experience into this.
So, this is one day after
we, in the United States,
commemorate Indigenous Peoples' Day
and I wanna locate myself
here on the traditional lands,
stewarded by the Quinnipiac People
who were subjected to violent mobilities
of colonial settlement
and forced displacement
that continue to shape the geography
of the U.S. settler state.
So, I'm really mindful when I talk about
mobility and violence in other contexts,
that I am very much interpolated,
both in that context
and in my home country, in
my home geography as well.
So, like Teresa said,
I'm hoping to talk to you
for about 30 to 35 minutes
and then we'll have time for discussion.
So, today I am drawing on my research
on the Euro-African border in Morocco
to make the case that race and racism
and especially in the
context that I investigate,
Blackness and anti-Blackness
are central to determinations
about whose mobility is subject to control
and how that works.
So, before I go any further though,
I wanna unpack a few terms.
So, when I talk about
the Euro-African border,
I'm speaking of the
network of governments,
law enforcement agencies,
humanitarian organizations,
defense contractors, smuggling
rings and other entities
that are implicated in the control
of people's migratory movements
between Africa and Europe.
And this network has grown out of the EU
and individual member states'
shift in the mid to late 1990s
toward outsourcing immigration control
to neighboring countries whose
participation is enlisted
through various diplomatic
and financial incentives.
And just a little side note,
Nora El Qadim is a
person who problematizes
maybe the incentivization
of the externalized borders,
so, if you wanna know more about that
I encourage you to look up her work.
Most scholars call this
sort of outsourced border,
the externalized border,
or border externalization
and you'll hear me refer to
it in this talk in that way.
So, in the externalized border,
walls and fences certainly play a role
and definitely draw much
of the media attention,
but the border signifies
something much more expansive.
It's a political and economic complex,
whose reason for being depends
upon the criminalization
of certain groups of people's
cross-border movements.
Further, borders aren't
just inner barriers,
be they physical,
institutional, algorithmic,
legal or social, but active processes
of inscribing, inclusions and exclusions
throughout social space.
So, in this way, borders are productive.
They aren't just about
restricting, or inhibiting,
but they're generating
relations, subjects and spaces.
So, when I talk about
race, I'm not referring
to unchanging identities, or categories
whose meaning is fixed
across time and space,
but instead I understand race
as a category of difference
produced through ongoing
processes of racialization
with local and transregional,
as well as historical
and contemporary valence.
So, what this means is it
being Black in Morocco,
for example, is not the same,
even though it resonates with
being Black in the United States.
And as we'll see in a bit,
neither is being white in Morocco
the same as being white in
the U.S. or in Mauritania,
or in South Africa, or
in countries in Europe.
When I argue that race
and especially Blackness
is central to mobility control
in the Euro-African borderlands,
it means it isn't just that the
border targets Black people,
but that it produces people as Black,
collapsing their multiple
identities into a single figure
of the Black, or African migrant.
And further, it assigns
meanings about Blackness
that legitimize the
violence against people
conceived as fundamentally out of place,
not just in Morocco or Europe,
but within the realm of the human.
And by the way, slides and pictures,
so you don't have to look at
me the whole time, are coming,
but I just wanna get
this introduction first.
So, to unpack this, I'm
gonna tell you a story
about a conversation I had
in the midst of field work
in 2017 and 2018 among West
and Central African migrants
who'd found themselves
stranded in Morocco.
The story points to the ways
that the Euoro-African border
is not just reorganizing
transnational economic relationships,
or challenging notions of
sovereignty and territory,
which are concerns that
border scholars have taken up,
but is reworking the
social and significant ways
across Morocco and, I
would argue by extension,
throughout the Euro-African borderlands.
My approach builds on
decades of feminist critique
of scale and ethnographic research
in order to understand how
the bodily and the global
mutually constitute places and people.
Thus thinking about the
border ethnic graphically,
requires attention to the
daily embodied experiences
of people who encounter,
reproduce and transgress it.
And in my work, I argue
that migrants are implicated
in all of those actions.
So, through a relational
lens, I trace connections
rather than distinctions
that characterize the border's operations
and migrants' experiences
in specific places
within, what Ruben Andersson calls,
the extended field sites,
the Euro-African border.
All right, so I'm gonna
share my screen with you now.
All right.
So, I conducted most of my
field work in Fes and Meknes
which are two Central Moroccan
cities that have been host
to growing numbers of West and
Central African populations.
This is in part due to
the Moroccan state shift
a few years previous to this research,
from a practice of apprehending migrants
in the Northern part of
Morocco, which I refer to
as the frontier region,
or the frontier zone,
near fences that separate Morocco
from two Spanish enclaves,
Melilla and Ceuta, Ceuta
that you can see on the map.
Formerly, the state had rounded up folks
attempting to breach the fences,
or cross the Mediterranean on boats,
or sometimes just rounded people up
who were phenotypically
Black in the Northern cities
and dropped them off in the
desert at the Algerian border.
This practice has been widely denounced
by human rights associations
in Morocco and in Europe,
and was replaced as part
of a humanitarian reform
of Morocco's border policy.
So, what replaced it instead
were these internal deportations
in which any Black non-citizen,
in the words of one report,
in the frontier zone
were still rounded up,
but rather than dropping
them in the desert,
they were (indiscernible)
to cities in the country's interior.
This practice of pushing people back
from the Northern border zone
to more remote Southern locations,
mirrors the EU's region-wide strategy
of pushing migrants from its
Southern and Eastern borders
into countries like
Morocco, Libya and Turkey.
These are countries that
have fewer resources
and infrastructures to accommodate them.
I think part of this
border externalization
and the pushing back that is happening,
or creating a buffer zone,
is something that just
keeps getting replicated,
replicated on a smaller and smaller scale.
So, once in Fes, or Meknes,
migrants were often dropped off
near the train station, or bus station
and encampments were
established in empty lots
adjacent to them.
And this is true, not
just in Fes or Meknes
but in many cities across the country.
Many people newly arrived
from the North state
in these encampments, are
moved to overcrowded rooms
in working class neighborhoods
where they survive
by begging on the street,
or engaged in informal work.
One effect of this policy, was
it heightened the visibility
of West and Central African migrants
on Moroccan city streets,
reinforcing the link
between Blackness and unauthorized,
or undesired migration.
This heightened visibility
and conflation of Blackness
with illegality, impacted
different communities
within Morocco in several ways.
First, it conceal the fact
that many of the people
migrating to Europe from
Morocco without papers,
were in fact Moroccan nationals.
Second, it reframed how people perceived
the presence of many Sub-Saharan
students with legal papers.
So, these Sub-Saharan students
have long been present in Morocco
and actually are brought to
Morocco through a program
that the state sponsors.
And finally, it's impacted Black Moroccans
whose belonging has
always been racialized,
but is now being animated by
anti-Black migration politics.
And that's kind of what
I'm gonna focus on today.
So, in Fes, I worked closely
with a research partner,
Freddy, or as he likes
to say, he had a driver.
Several times a week I would
meet him at the McDonald's
in downtown Fes, where we
would have a quick breakfast
and then spend the next six or so hours
visiting migrant communities
in the outdoor encampment
adjacent to the train station,
or in a working class neighborhood.
Freddy wears lots of hats.
Himself a former migrant from Cameroon,
he took the land journey from Morocco
when he was a teenager.
He's now a social worker
with a church-based NGO
and with a Moroccan-based NGO
focused on HIV prevention.
He's also the leader of
the Cameroonian community
by virtue of his seniority in the country
and his important positions with NGOs.
In his social worker role,
he responds to urgent health
and social services needs
of all Black people,
as he says, in Fes.
People from Cameroon, Nigeria,
Guinea, Mali, Ivory Coast,
and so on.
His phone never stops ringing,
rounding up blankets
for newly-arrived people
dropped off at the camp by
a Moroccan border police,
calling supervisors to ask
for the release of funds
so he can pay for prescriptions
for migrants who are
experiencing hypertension,
or to purchase insulin for diabetes.
He's accompanied pregnant
women to their prenatal visits
to provide translation,
identifies bodies at the morgue
and arranges for a burial
in a pauper's grave,
helps someone arrange
their self-deportation
and will file applications
for one-year regularization program
for mothers and children.
And as Cameroonian community
leader, he mediates disputes
between individuals who
visits people in prison,
and while I was there,
arranged for a sex worker
who was not getting along with her madam
to be transferred to a
madam in another city
so that she could be safe.
Often when I dropped him
off in the neighborhood
in the early evening,
he had hours more calls
and visits to make.
So, after six, or seven
months as Freddy's chauffeur,
I took a short vacation to the Tafilalet,
located in the Southeast of the country
near Morocco's fabled sand dunes.
The Tafilalet oasis system
runs along the Ziz River
between the provincial capital of Rachidia
to the north in Erfoud,
the gateway to the Sahara
as tourist operators like
to say, to the south.
The Tafilalet has fascinated
generations of anthropologists
also for its diverse,
entangled, cultural, religious,
racial and ethnic makeup, Arabs, Jews,
Black or Arab Berbers,
descendants of slaves,
so-called white Berbers,
descendants of the prophet,
the Shorfa, or of holy people, and so on.
And we can talk more
about that in the Q&A,
or I can point you to
some excellent resources
including Hussein Al Lahyan's work.
So, though I didn't
travel to the Tafilalet
to study the border, I
encountered it anyway.
The internal deportations
that it contributed
to more West and Central African migrants
living in and stranded in Fes and Meknes,
were now being diverted to more remote
and economically marginal
towns, further south,
or further in the Moroccan interior,
including both Rachidia and Erfoud,
each a short distance away
from where this picture was taken.
Indeed, in Fes I met many
people who'd been pushed back
from the Northern border to
Rachidia, to Beni Mellal,
or to Tiznit, before making
their way back to Fes,
or heading back to the Northern frontier
to try to cross the border again.
On my visit to the Tafilalet,
I was chatting with Fatima Zahra,
an Amazigh or Berber activist,
about my research among migrants
experiencing these internal deportations
and how I thought the practice
seemed to be reinforcing,
or intensifying anti-Black discrimination
against both migrants and Black Moroccans.
She responded with the local
version of the argument
I've heard many times since
moving to Morocco in 2001.
In the Tafilalet there have
been African immigrants
for centuries as a result of
the Trans-Saharan slave trade,
but despite their unfree status,
they suffered no discrimination
in Moroccan society.
Pointing to a sepia-toned picture
of a traditionally garbed
man on the wall, she said,
"My grandfather owned two slaves
"and he treated them very well."
The problem, in her view, arose
from changes in land tenure,
that it allowed, Le Noir, by
which she was referring to
both the descendants of
enslaved West Africans
and Indigenous Black, or Arab Berbers,
access to property formerly
controlled by, Le Blanc,
which would be non-Black Berbers.
In addition, because descendants
of enslaved and Black Indigenous people
were now considered
members of tribal groups,
they were able to sit on local councils
and influence decisions about developing,
or selling off communal land.
She traced a square on
the table with her fingers
and added, "Now that African
migrants are arriving
"in the region, the Amazigh are
being invaded on all sides."
There are many things that we
can unpack about this vignette
that speak to the specific
character of racial politics
in Morocco, including
questions of indigeneity,
race, descent, property
regimes, kinship and filiation.
But what really struck me about
these very local struggles
with decades, and in some
cases, centuries of...
Built on centuries-old
categories of social difference
and corresponding power
and resource inequalities,
was that they were being interpolated
into this very recent
transnational Euro-African border.
So, what I'm gonna spend the
rest of our time on today
is showing how the border
is producing the social,
especially in regards to race,
in places far from the walls and fences
and how the politics
of belonging in Morocco
is increasingly being articulated
in the register of race.
And I wanna touch briefly
on how outsourcing,
or externalizing border enforcement
from Europe to its neighbors,
can enable the concealment
of European culpability,
but it also can offer a way
to trace the border's logics,
and operations across vast spaces.
Next, I'll discuss
Morocco's racial history
in contemporary context in
which the border intervenes.
And then finally, while
Blackness is consolidated
as a signifier of otherness,
I propose that it has facilitated,
or deepened mobilizations
against white supremacy throughout
the Euro-African border.
(pages rustling)
Teresa, I'm assuming you will intervene
if there's something going wrong,
so I'm just gonna keep
going 'cause all I see
is the PowerPoint.
I just found this map and
I think it's wonderful
because it gives you a sense
of this externalized border.
According to this map,
the blue dotted line,
which goes through the Mediterranean,
is sort of where the
European border is imagined.
I'm not exactly sure why
it runs through Turkey
in this case, but
maybe we can talk about that.
(Leslie chuckles)
But then you have the neighbors,
you have North Africa who,
North African countries who participate
in containing and preventing migrants from
their own people and then
also from other places,
from reaching, or crossing that border.
And then I think what this map also shows
is that the externalized border
is moving further and further south
through various other kinds
of research partnerships,
so that the whole journey
from, say for example,
Cameroon to Libya, or to
Morocco is heavily bordered
and is overlaid with various agreements
between states and
contractors and other people.
So, my colleague, Lorena Gazzotti and I
recently authored a piece that
subjects analytical concepts
common to border and migration studies,
to post-colonial critique.
We argue that uncritical
use of externalization
runs the risk of reproducing
colonial narratives
of Europe as the agent of history.
Following (indiscernible) in Syria,
we argue that externalizations presentism
the idea that it's unique and
also that migration is new,
or is a crisis, is ahistorical.
European powers have been
subverting African autonomy
for centuries as Martin
Lumbar Peterson has argued,
and imposing various mobility
regimes that facilitate,
or suppress the movement
of precarious people.
Nevertheless, externalization
also enables us
to move beyond uncritical
analyses of border enforcement
that center individual states.
So, it allows us to
trace relations of power
in circuits of capital that structure
the transnational, heterogeneous
Euro-African border.
When used critically and historically,
externalization can help
us discern the connections
that obtain across scales
and among different actors.
By bringing such connections to the fore,
we can track transnational
circulations of race
and racist ideologies that
are central to the animation
of local, specific racial
formations and histories
in places like Morocco.
So, I'm gonna talk a little
bit about these histories
before turning to how they articulate
with border externalization
in Morocco today.
(object thudding)
Wonder if I can move this.
I don't know if you guys,
if that's in the way.
Oh, well, I'll just leave it.
For a long time there's been silence
around the subject of race in Morocco,
both in public conversations,
but also in academic scholarship
where it's often folded into
discussions of ethnicity.
Despite this silence,
race and racialization
permeate Moroccan and Maghrebi societies.
Chouki El Hamel points to the
pre-colonial and Islamic roots
or the Black, white binary,
suggesting that perhaps
the Islamic Mediterranean
influenced, or shaped
the racial hierarchies
that became entrenched in the Americas.
The Trans-Saharan slave trade reverberates
in Moroccan social relations as evidenced
by the use of the word, al abd, slave,
to refer to a dark-skinned Moroccan
and the persistent idea that
phenotypically Black Berbers
are not actually Indigenous.
The colonial project in
Morocco and across Africa
has linked whiteness to
superiority and modernity
and Blackness to tradition, prehistory
and under-development.
Today, the accretion of
anti-Blackness is discernible
in myriad ways that
include racial profiling
by security agents, the
casual use of racist language
by ordinary Moroccans and
the frequent appearance
of blackface and racial stereotypes
in entertainment and media.
And you can see an example here.
This was a really famous
example that came out recently
because Mariam Hussein here,
is expressing her solidarity
with U.S. protests,
the Black Lives Matter
protests in the United States,
in the wake of the murder of George Floyd.
And the way that she
decided to do this was
to wear blackface.
So, as anthropologist,
Laura Menin has argued,
racial formations and racism
are local particular and contextual.
This is a common position
among both historians
and anthropologists working
on questions of difference
in the Maghreb and the
African continent as a whole.
What's important about this perspective
is that it safeguards
against imposing analyses,
or theories derived from other
contexts to the Moroccan one.
But going back to the
point made at the beginning
about scale, context is never only local.
And indeed the local is
always bound up in relations
that extend well beyond
the particular location.
I think Fatima Zahra's story
gets at both this relationality
and its contingency.
Morocco is not a blank slate
when it comes to race relations
or racial politics, but
neither is it closed off
from the past or present
global racial ideologies
and geopolitics.
Tracing the border as it
connects as well as separates
Africa and Europe,
makes it possible to see
how race circulates, is
transnationally constituted
and bound up in systems of power
that cut across local and international,
reworking, intensifying,
unsettling and refusing meanings
in various places.
So again, Europe's outsourced
border enforcement program
and the ensemble that now
comprises the Euro-African border
is impacting, not only
notions of Blackness,
but reinforcing hegemonic
conceptions of whiteness
across Moroccan social space.
Blackness, which has long been
a signifier of inferiority
in Morocco, has become
consolidated with illegality,
with riskiness and with out-of-placeness,
sticking to Yusira Ahmed's
term, to other people
who are not explicitly the
targets of border violence.
So, this is a case with Timothy Hucks.
Timothy Hucks was a U.S.
English teacher who,
while living in Rabat,
was rounded up by police
and internally deported to
the south of the country.
He had stepped out of his
house to run a quick errand
and left his passport at home.
Police did not believe
that he as a Black man,
was a U.S. citizen
and thought he was an
undocumented migrant.
Lorena Gazzotti has written
about how in Morocco,
Black people are routinely
policed and deported
regardless of their legal
status, while at the same time,
white Europeans who overstay their visas,
can expect few consequences,
none of them violent, or immediate.
While Hucks eventually returned to Rabat
and then to the United States,
and I think his citizenship
had something to do with
his ability to move,
Alain Toussaint, another
teacher and legal resident,
originally from the
Democratic Republic of Congo,
was similarly rounded up and died
after being thrown from a moving bus
during an internal deportation.
(pages rustling)
So, oh, sorry.
So, the conflation of
Blackness with out-of-placeness
attaches to Black Moroccans as well.
During field work, Black
Moroccans recounted examples
of how other Moroccans
would mutter racial epithets
under their breath, like
at the hanut or market,
assuming that the person didn't
understand Moroccan Arabic.
And in a poignant example
that a friend told me about,
in 2017, he was watching a sports program
and a Moroccan TV journalist
was on the streets
in Casablanca interviewing people
about an upcoming soccer match.
When the journalist
encountered a Black Moroccan,
he switched to French assuming
the man was a foreigner.
The man replied in Moroccan Arabic.
They went back and forth like this
with the interviewer not
believing the man was Moroccan
until he finally said in exasperation,
"(speaking in foreign
language)," long live the king.
In contrast, whiteness
has gained more salience
as a way to assert one's
authorization in a space
at the national scale,
but also at other scales.
So, like Fatima Zahra, many
Moroccans that I spoke to
would probably refer to their
identity as white in ref...
I'm sorry,
Their identity as Muslim, Arab,
or Berber, perhaps Jewish,
or, more commonly, just Moroccan,
but referred to themselves as
white in reference to Black,
or African migrants.
So, drawing a distinction between
so-called African migrants
and themselves, helped
them to fix a boundary
that aligns the Maghreb with Europe
at the expense of producing Africa,
using the language of European
apartheid as beyond the pale.
The global pandemic has
exposed how harm is directed
to racialized, gendered and othered people
in society structured in dominance.
The murder of George
Floyd and Breonna Taylor,
in my country, has
provoked worldwide protests
in solidarity with Black U.S. citizens,
but it's also prompted
testimonies from Black Arabs
and other Black Middle Eastern
and North African people
about the pervasive
discrimination that exists
both in the diaspora and
in their home countries.
Significantly, many of them are naming
the marginalization
violence they experience
as anti-Blackness and
expressing solidarity
with Black migrants in
other African diasporas.
So, these are two social media campaigns
that I wanna just talk
about for a few minutes.
There are many of them
that have proliferated in recent years.
Or in recent months, I should say.
So, qahwa.nessness and Black Moroccans
are providing platforms for
Black-identifying Moroccans
and members of the Moroccan diaspora.
Black Moroccans, as far as I can tell,
is also affiliated with
activists and artists
who were involved in the 2014
campaign, "Masmiytich Azzi,"
which is, "My name is not Azzi,"
Azzi connoting a very pejorative
word for a Black person.
So, both of these Instagram accounts,
like other accounts that
focus on the Gulf, or Iran,
or the Arab world as a whole,
are comprised of a mix of historical
and contemporary images
of Blackness in Morocco,
as well as testimonies of Black
and Afro-identified people
speaking to their experiences
with anti-Blackness
in their home countries.
And this is one example.
I think that this is the
organizer of qahwa.halfhalf,
but I haven't gotten in
touch yet to confirm that.
So, many of these testimonies
explicitly point out
that racism is not just
something that happens
in the United States or in Europe,
but it's something that's also
woven into Moroccan society.
And these Instagram
accounts provide a platform
where Moroccan nationals and
Europeans of Moroccan descent
reject the pressures to
orient toward whiteness,
instead embracing
Blackness and Africanity,
along with Moroccaness,
Europeanness, Indigeneity, or Arabness.
They write and speak about
identity and sociality
in ways that destabilize,
not only the Manichaeanisms
of Black, white binaries,
but also monolithic ideas
about racial identity and belonging.
Their commentaries invoke the local
and Moroccan specificity of
Blackness and anti-Blackness
and how these are
entangled in transnational
and transtemporal notions
of value and humanity.
I think these are really exciting.
I could go on a...
I'm gonna wrap up really soon,
but I can talk about
these for a long time.
So, tracing the afterlives of slavery
and European colonialism,
they connect the condition
of the Haratin in Morocco
and Mauritania to that
of la-bas in France.
They interrogate the
role of anti-Blackness
in Islamic history and jurisprudence.
They protest foreign capitalists
and militaristic interventions and so on.
Their epistemological vision
is relational and social,
simultaneously grounded
in place and specificity
and mindful of the larger crosscurrents
that we all get drawn into.
Black Moroccans, with its
roots in immigrant solidarity
and anti-racist activism and
the more recent qahwa.halfhalf,
emerge from, I would
argue, (speaking French)
shaped by the Euro-African
border's production
of Blackness as otherness.
The transnational project
of bordering Blackness
has also enabled West and
Central African migrants,
Black Moroccans, Moroccans in the diaspora
experiencing anti-Islamic,
or anti-Black discrimination
to assemble a transnational
African diaspora
that refuses Blackness as negation,
and instead understands Blackness
as conditioning the possibility
for new internationalist
and de-colonial features.
I think that's the last example, yeah.
Okay, so
I think Teresa is gonna help me do this,
but if you have questions,
you can put them in the chat.
Or I don't know.
What do you think, Teresa,
they can unmute themselves?
- Yeah, they can unmute themselves.
There was already one question
on the chat from Tasleem
about the
map that you show, so I
could think if you want to,
if you want to show, ask
the question yourself?
- Sure, okay, yeah.
So, thanks for the question, Tasleem.
So, you said, "Are the yellow bits
"countries that are
partnering with North Africa
"to protect the red border?"
I think a lot of that...
I guess I will go back to it.
But I think that most of this,
because a lot of the funding
is still driven by the European Union,
these are partnerships that comprise,
sort of multiple layers of partners
that include, often Europeans,
North African states and
states in this Sahara and
Western Africa, for example.
So, I don't think it's
tiered in the sense that
Morocco and Tunisia and Algeria and Libya
cooperate with Europe and then,
you know, Mali and Mauritania and Niger
cooperate with Morocco and
Algeria, but instead it's,
you know, it's these
multiple layers of programs
that contribute to that across the board.
And I see a question from Lydia
that asks if there are
any Moroccan researchers
working on these topics,
Blackness, externalized, borders,
et cetera, in Moroccan universities.
So, I think the answer to
that is yes, there are.
Particularly working on the topic
of the externalized border,
there are quite a few,
both doing research,
I mean, affiliated with
institutions in Europe
and North America, but also
working within Morocco.
When I first came to do research in 2017,
I met with three researchers from Meknes
who were doing phenomenal
work on the border
and on migrant experiences there.
And I am...
(indiscernible) is the last name.
I'm blanking temporarily on their names,
but I can pass them along.
In addition, my colleague
and I, Lorena and I,
just co-edited a volume
for the Journal of North African Studies
that came out online this summer,
that features a few people,
a few researchers, from the
region and actually one migrant
who is speaking about
the externalized border
and their experience in Morocco.
So, yeah, so that's some of that.
In terms of Blackness, I do
think that there are some people
from the North African diaspora
who are starting to ask these questions.
University of Pennsylvania,
their Middle East Studies Department there
has had some really interesting work.
I'm really bad with names.
Afifa Latifi, I believe is
I think from Tunisia and is doing that,
is thinking about these questions
from a historical point, perspective.
And yes, of course,
(indiscernible) points out as well.
Said Sadiqi has been talking
about this for a long time.
And then of course, in terms of Blackness,
Chouki El Hamel literally wrote the book
on Blackness in Morocco.
And that book has recently
been translated into Arabic.
Okay, Zeenab asked,
what did I mean by
relational epistemologies?
And this is when I was talking
about the Instagrammers.
I think the emphasis that I'm
trying to make here is that
these phenomena are neither
local, completely local,
nor completely
de-territorialized, or global only,
but they are constantly
in relation to each other.
And that also, the way that
these protests are seeing them themselves
is not in a comparative
sense where they're trying to
show that anti-Blackness
in Morocco, for example,
is commensurate with maybe anti-Arab,
or anti-Islamic racism in
France, but trying to constitute
or organized,
organize solidarities that recognize
that a lot of this has to
do with white supremacy,
it has to do with capitalist development
and even development in the world.
And it has to do with
long histories of colonial
intervention as well.
Any other questions?
I'm also really happy to
hear comments from folks too.
'Cause I imagine you have opinions.
(Leslie laughs)
Okay, so Iman said,
"I was wondering if you
could talk a little more
"about how the presence of
Sub-Saharan Africans in Morocco
"conceals the fact that many of the people
"migrating to Europe from Morocco
"are actually Moroccan nationals
"and how that affects the
Morocco EU relationship?"
Thanks for that question.
These are really great
questions, all of them.
Yeah, so I think...
This is something that I talk about
in some of my other work, but
the way that I think about it
is that in Morocco's participation
in the externalized border is often framed
as containing, or preventing the mobility
of people from Sub-Saharan Africa.
And as many of us know, Moroccan nationals
constitute the largest non,
largest non-national population in Europe,
many of whom, of course,
arrived by legal means,
but not all.
But it's reworking.
When I first moved to Morocco in 2001,
there was a lot of discussion,
and you see this in literature as well,
a lot of discussion
about Moroccan migrants,
or Moroccan immigrants who
are trying to get to Europe.
And I feel like that discourse has shifted
despite the fact that
really the numbers of people
moving from Morocco to Europe,
from West or Central Africa
are still quite small.
So, I think it reframes,
for Morocco it reframes
the problem of migration
if migration is at all a problem,
as something that is from outside,
that is from West or Central Africa,
rather than something that is,
that is related to Moroccan
nationals themselves,
if that makes sense.
And of course, the EU is also
addressing the issue of
Moroccan national migration.
But one of the things that they do
in exchange for Morocco's cooperation,
is offer more short-term visas
for agricultural laborers
and people like that,
as well as student visas
and facilitate some of the ways
for people to go work in Europe,
or join family in Europe more easily.
But some of that is, at least in theory,
contingent upon Morocco's cooperation
in keeping West and Central Africans out,
or keeping them from crossing the border.
Does that make sense, Iman?
- [Iman] Yeah, thank you so much.
- This is Tasleem.
I wanted to ask you if
you see parallels in
this situation here
relative to the U.S.
South American, like
we have this caravan...
I'm just gonna use the
words even here are used.
So, the caravan coming through and then
the U.S. trying to partner with Mexico
to make that border further.
I mean, it kinda reminded me
of this whole situation here
when you described the Moroccan situation.
I'm wondering what are the
parallels and differences?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
I think there's a lot.
(Leslie chuckles)
I think there are a lot of parallels.
And now I'm gonna just make
things up, but I feel like
the EU sort of pioneered this
and the U.S. jumped on-board,
but I could be wrong about that.
But I do know from people
doing research in Mexico,
that there's increasing numbers
of Central American migrants
who are stuck in Mexico and
the U.S. is pushing them back.
Instead of...
They're trying to intercept
them before they cross,
or right as they cross the border
so that they don't have to deport them.
They can push them back into Mexico
and then it becomes Mexico's problem.
And the conditions for Central Americans
has gotten much worse.
And my understanding from, you now,
from folks, either doing
research in Mexico,
or actually just from Mexicans
that are living there,
is that discrimination
and sort of anti-Indigenous
racism against Central
Americans, has become a huge...
Has become significant in the way that
the Central American
migration is characterized now
in Mexico.
And I think the U.S. I don't know...
I know that the U.S. funds some of that,
just the way that the EU funds it,
but Donald Trump apparently
doesn't know that, so.
(Both chuckle)
- Because that also the...
I think you called it the frontier zone,
it's starting to feel like that too,
on that border on the
Mexican side of the border
of that space where--
- Yeah.
- people who are stuck
or setting up.
- Completely
and now that asylum claims
are either not being processed,
or processed so slowly,
that there's just an...
More and more people are
amassing on that border.
And then of course, you know,
the United States has a
hundred mile buffer zone
around all of its borders.
So, that's another thing.
And it can act with a
certain level of impunity
that doesn't apply in other
places in American territory.
Yeah.
- Hi, thank you so much,
Leslie, for your talk.
I was curious if you
can speak to the sort of
humanitarian laws governing
these deportations
because I am curious.
I am thinking so much
about African migrants
who are going into Italy and
you have these Italian boats
that are supposed to save them
and then you have these asylum laws
and you have, of course,
the humanitarian laws
that they can't, you know...
I don't know, I think I
encountered this concept of
(speaking foreign language)
in thinking about the
South American border
where you can't legally send
people back, who are in danger.
So, is there any sort of....
I mean, this partnership between the EU
is, I guess, quite concerning
when thinking about the laws
that also the EU and the UN uphold
in terms of humanitarianism.
- Yeah, that's a great question.
(Leslie sighs)
Well, I'll just say the first
thing that comes to my mind is
I get so mad when people are
rescued in the Mediterranean
by being sent back to Libya, right?
Or I get Morocco.
I'd Google where it says
Morocco and migrants
and they'll say like
Moroccan coast guard rescued
a certain amount of migrants
in the Mediterranean
when really it's intercepting
and pushing them back,
or bringing them back
to Moroccan territory.
So, that discourses,
humanitarian discourses,
get really enmeshed.
And that isn't to say that there
isn't rescue also happening
in the Mediterranean,
but those discourses get
really enmeshed with security
and with securitization.
And so, it's a really
complicated situation.
In 2014, Morocco, for which
they should be lauded,
reformed their migration policy.
Some of the things that
they did was to offer
two periods of exceptional regularization,
where people could actually
get residency permits
for a year or more, a year
and it could be renewed.
In addition they, at least on
paper, at least aspirationally
would provide healthcare
and education for kids
and for other people.
I'm trying to think what
else off the top of my head.
But those were pretty significant,
particularly if we think,
if you compare them to
the context in the
United States right now,
it is something to be lauded.
But what it did is kind of put people,
it kept people from traveling
where they wanted to travel
and in some cases, it just
put them on hold
because they were still
not able to get jobs,
they were still experiencing
police violence,
they were still at the
risk of being rounded up
at any moment and being
mistaken for someone
that didn't have residency papers.
Also, there were limits in
terms of who got regularized
and who didn't and how long
you had to have been there
and whether you were
there at the right time.
So, I think actually
probably a little bit more
than in the United States-Mexico context,
humanitarian language and
sort of liberal discourses
about human rights get deployed a lot,
but not necessarily...
They're not inscribed
into law in the same way.
And,
you know, just to do a
little bit more press,
(Leslie chuckles)
or shameless promotion,
the Journal of North African Studies
special issue that just came out on this
has some articles that
specifically address that.
And one of them is by Katharina
Natter and she talks about
how the sort of liberal
discourse in humanitarianism
on the Moroccan state enables
it to be authoritarian
in other ways.
So,
we have Herach conflict,
or repression, I guess you would say
and we're seeing a lot more media
experiencing oppression in Morocco.
Women have been subjected to court cases
related to their sexuality
and things like that.
So, there is a way too, in
which this humanitarian language
conceals other kinds of behavior.
So, those are some of the
things that I'm thinking of
off the top of my head.
Does that answer your question, Faith?
- Yes, thank you so much.
- Okay, great.
Jennifer, you said...
Yes, "When you talk about
resistance to the fact
"or regarding..."
Jennifer, can you tell me what you said?
I missed the first part.
Can you clarify?
- [Jennifer] Sorry, I had
(indiscernible) deleted.
- No, it's okay.
- I'm--
- I do that all the time.
- I was just (sound cuts out)
how you talked about (indiscernible)
against Black indigeneity
and just this discourse
around Blackness of
not belonging to place.
And so, I'm curious if
there's also settler claims
to indigeneity going on here
with anyone else who's not
necessarily from Morocco
who necessarily identify as
Black and still gets the access?
- Right.
So, there's a lot going
on that I understand some,
but I'm really not the pers...
So, I'm gonna gesture to some things,
but I would not be the person
to unpack this in detail.
But first, indigeneity is
kind of a weird concept.
I think it translates kind of...
I use that, but it translates strangely,
partly because of the French.
There's a little bit of
(speaking foreign language)
happening there in Morocco.
But this denial of Black indigeneity,
or maybe Black (speaking
Arabic), identity,
has to do with this
conflation with Blackness
and slavery that Chouki
El Hamel talks about.
So, the idea is, if you're Black,
you're always from somewhere else.
And very common, the most
common term that I heard
when I lived in Morocco,
that people would address Black people by
was (speaking Arabic),
person from the South,
I mean, from the Sahara.
And so, this idea that you're
from another geography,
from another place, would
deny your right to presence.
But there's also this dynamic in Morocco,
where Morocco itself is
a settler state, right,
'cause it's occupying Western Sahara
and there's all kinds of really
interesting racial dynamics
in Western Sahara as well.
So, yeah.
So, there's a lot going on there
that I think would be fascinating
for someone to unpack,
but it's not the main
focus for me, right now.
The region, the Tafilalet,
where this came out for me,
is such an interesting and
diverse and varied region
with a lot of history and culture
that I haven't fully
apprehended, or investigated.
And so, I think someone who
would do a really nuanced study
of some of these
questions, would do well to
kind of dive into that literature
and think about it from that aspect.
- [Jennifer] Thank you.
- Yeah, no problem.
Lydia, have I studied the
specificities of Blackness
in Rabat, the capital?
I haven't, I haven't, no.
(Leslie chuckles)
This is actually, in some ways,
this paper is the follow-up to my research
because the bulk of my
research is really focused
on how the Euro-African border
produces migrants as Black
in order to legitimize
violence against them
and sort of to consign them
to this other place, right,
to this
zone of non-being, if you
wanna put it that way,
or the un-geographic
is how Katherine
McKittrick talks about it.
And then I also think about
it in terms of political economy.
But the,
the way that the border was
impacting Moroccan society
more broadly, and I could
see this a little bit
as kind of an outsider
that was traveling and
living there frequently.
I moved there the first time in 2001,
just a few weeks before September
11th in the United States.
And then returned periodically
for one or two year periods
through 2017.
So, I was able to see how this sort of
this Blackness, illegality,
migrationist crisis,
all of this discourse
was becoming more and
more prominent in Morocco
over the two decades or so that I've been
living, or moving around there.
So, definitely, you
know, I've heard things
similar about Rabat,
but I haven't done a
particular study of Rabat.
Okay, Zeenab
says, "I've read about how
Moroccan authorities have a habit
"of quelling the formation
of anti-racist civil society
"for a variety of possible reasons."
Have I been pressured in any way,
or approached by the authorities
while conducting my research?
No, that's, you know...
So, one of my external
advisers is Michael Collier
who's been doing research
on migration in Morocco
in the region since 1997.
And he's really careful to emphasize
that one of the reasons we're
able to talk about Morocco
as a violent border state
or, racism in Morocco,
or things like that,
is in part because they allow researchers
to come and ask some of these questions.
So, you know, you can't do
this research in Algeria
as easily, at least as an
American, as a U.S. citizen.
So, in that sense, no,
I haven't been limited.
In another sense, you do have
to get a research permit.
So, I was encouraged
by my host organization
to be really careful about
how I framed these questions
and to speak in generalities.
In fact, my partner was
doing historical research
on the Rif, which is
sort of a much more...
It was right in the
midst of the Herach Rifi
kind of movement there
and he wasn't given a
research permit and in fact,
was told not to do research.
So, I think it varies by topic.
But Morocco has been fairly
accommodating to people
who are doing research
on migration despite
most of that research being
pretty strong in critique.
- [Female Speaker] If we
have a couple of minutes,
if there's not other questions,
I'm interested to know
a bit more about this political
economy that you mentioned.
And I think that was
a big part of your research and
how it feeds into this whole situation?
- Right, yeah.
So, you know, in some ways
I'm still puzzling that
out a little bit, but
there's an anthropologist,
Ruben Andersson.
There've been some other people as well,
but he really wrote about
the border, like this transnational border
between Europe and Africa as an industry
that exists to kind of circulate capital
based on the illegality,
or the production of
illegality of migrants.
And other scholars have done that too.
So, the idea is, again, that
the border can only exist
as long as you're criminalizing
people who are moving
and beyond that, that it
feeds, it feeds itself by,
through the accumulation of capital.
I'll give an example to be less abstract.
So, basically when Europe
infuses money into,
grants big defense contractors...
In the 1990s, you have to remember,
this is after the fall of the Berlin Wall
and the Cold War was
sort of officially over
and so suddenly you had all
these defense contractors
who didn't have markets
anymore to sell their,
to sell their wares, or their weapons
and their technologies,
so they repackage them
for civilian use and have advertised them
as being able to track migrants
and to protect migrants,
is one of the ways, one of
the languages that they use.
So, that sort of has kept the
defense industry for a while.
That kept them going for
a while and it's become,
you know, the expenditures
have become higher and higher.
And I would point to the
Transnational Institute
and Mark Akkerman,
who is someone who's
done research on that.
And then of as borders get stronger
and it gets harder to get
across, you'd have smugglers
who are also suddenly not
making a little bit of money,
just helping someone,
directing them through
the desert somewhere,
but suddenly having to
buy gear and night vision
and all of these things
and also can charge
a lot more money to migrants
and refugees who wanna cross
because it's gotten a lot more dangerous
and they need their specialized expertise.
So, there's a certain group
in the south of Algeria
who, I think, during the refugee crisis of
2015, said they made something
like a billion dollars.
I mean, I don't know if it's true or not,
but there's tremendous money in that.
So, what I do is try to link that to race
and think about it through
racial capitalist lens,
where it's not just the
production of illegality,
criminalizing people, but it's
also the production of race
that, making people who are
Black and are on the move,
targets of the border, both
defense contractors, states,
but also humanitarian
agencies and also smugglers,
all of these people are trying
to get a piece of the pie.
It's driven by sort of a racial logic.
So, that's where I connect
those two things together.
And I'm still thinking
through how that works
and what the utility of a
racial capitalist idea is,
but I think it also...
Political economy we often think of
as centered around labor and
I don't think this is centered
just around labor.
It's not just about bringing
people from Africa to Europe
in precarious condition
and being to able to exploit their labor,
but it's actually just
exploiting their movements
and their bodies and
making money off of that.
So, that's what I'm focused on.
Does that make sense?
Go ahead.
- Hey, Leslie.
First of all, I'm so sorry
'cause I missed the bulk of your talk
and I think could just get
last five minutes 'cause
I had actually prior meeting.
But I find this really
fascinating just from the Q&A
and the question that are being asked.
But I just wanna...
Probably my question more on your research
and I find that, and
you just mentioned this,
my understanding is that
lately there has been
sort of strict rules actually
in getting your permission
as far as sort of migration, because,
and you actually mentioned
this just earlier,
the fact that it's sort of paradoxical
that the state would give you permission
and you have to go through
all these loopholes.
However, a lot of the
research that's been produced
is sort of scathing to the state,
or sort of scathing critique of the state.
And I'd like just to hear
a little bit from you
as far as the generalization
that you've mentioned,
sort of to get research research permit,
you have to somewhat tweak your questions,
which can be problematic sometimes
'cause there's always this
sort of like, oh, you...
And I know this very well.
I know people that wanted to
do research in Western Sahara
and they would not even be allowed
to actually even come close to there,
or even have any sort of interlocutors,
which is really, really hard.
Anybody that would
even envision they would
do the research there
would not be even...
I know someone that tried to,
sort of tried to work on
divorce and tweak things
to be able to get even to that territory.
Sort of long-winded, but could you,
you know, could you say a bit about it
because it's really sometimes so hard
because also when you're doing research
and you want to get your research permit,
there are all these committees
and things you go through
that you have to sort of say
here is what I'm really doing.
And at times you might also have to...
I think about Egypt, just
to give you an example.
You talk about Algeria where
at times people even having
you know, one had to
apply for the Fulbright
and actually get the
Fulbright, they were rejected
because there are certain questions that
the way they formulated the questions
sort of was not welcomed by
the committee, or by the state.
I just wanna hear a little bit about,
especially that you've spent
a lot of time in the Morocco
back and forth with your partner
and doing lot of work there,
are there any...
Probably you had a very,
you know, very clear road.
You didn't have a lot of obstacles
also probably because of your affiliation.
But I wanna hear more, this
sort of tension between,
yes, you can get your permit, however,
it's a very oppressive
system that's really careful
about what people write about it
and still there's scathing critique.
I hope I'm making sense.
- Yeah, totally, totally.
I think I'll answer that question.
I'll zoom out a little bit
to sort of ethics in general
and also just my position.
Not only am I a white American,
but I had a research affiliation
with a very prominent
university in Morocco,
Al Akhawayn University
and I have a long history with them.
So, I was leveraging a lot of my privilege
that other researchers
might not have access to.
You know, if you're South African,
(male speaker chuckles)
you're not,
they're not gonna let
you come to the country
probably much less,
must less to do research
and there's lots of other examples.
So, I think that was part of it.
And actually I mentioned talking
to the three Meknesi researchers
when I was first starting and I was like,
well, how do you go about getting access,
you know, going into the
camps and stuff like that?
And they said, oh,
you're a white American.
No problem, you just
walk right in, you know?
And so, there were ways
in which that position,
for better or worse
and probably for worse,
enabled me to do that.
In terms of generalities,
I'll be really honest.
I'm an over-discloser,
if you haven't noticed
that already in this talk.
And I wrote out very
detailed research proposal
for the Ministry of Foreign Affairs
and the Ministry of Interior
and then somebody else
that was in the sponsoring institution,
edited it for me.
(both laughing)
so.
And you know, probably had
a better eye for the sort of
political nature
(indiscernible)
of how to act and how I should do it.
But I mean, I think there's an ethics too,
to what you disclose and
what you don't disclose
and how you...
Yeah.
And also what you go in expecting to see.
I think my situation
was a little different
because I'd been in Morocco for so long
and had already encountered
the experience of being with migrants
who were experiencing violence
and over-policing and things like that,
so I kind of knew what I
was probably gonna find.
But I think we also
have to think about that
and be really careful for
going in, expecting to find
racism, or expecting to
overlay our particular
epistemological orientation
onto a new context.
You know, that can be
problematic as well, so.
Yeah, so, I think it is something...
And I think it was helpful for me
that I was affiliated with
a Moroccan institution,
not just for the,
you know, for the kind
of greasing the wheels,
but also because it kept me
a little bit more accountable
to scholars who were doing similar work,
who were from the country,
or who were long-term
residents of the country.
So, I didn't feel like I was
quite so much of a lone cowboy
doing a lot of this work
and had some accountability,
not just to my research interlocutors,
Western Central African
migrants, but also to other folks
in the region who were experts on this
and were asking me questions
and talking through these
issues with me as well.
- [Male Speaker] Thank
you so much, Leslie.
The reason really a way to ask you that
'cause I know someone
who recently actually
wanted to do similar work
and it was actually rejected.
But you're right.
The whole politics of
access and affiliation,
I mean, it absolutely makes total sense.
Thank you.
- No problem.
And I will say, I think Morocco
is getting a little stricter
on research permits, so that is true.
- There is a question from Liz Chrismar
about the data (indiscernible)
(indiscernible) and also (indiscernible)
So, if you can reply
to these two questions,
I think this will be the last two ones.
- Okay.
So Liz, I don't know if I can talk about
the externalization of
the border in Morocco
and how it plays out through
technology and data collection.
In part, because a lot of the...
From the state perspective,
the Ministry of Interior,
is the one who keeps the
most accurate, and I'm sure,
exhaustive data on this and
they're not telling anyone.
So, that's sort of a black box.
I know that in terms of UNHCR
migrants are fingerprinted
now, and that has to do with
where people can make asylum claims
and this push to get people
to seek asylum in Morocco
and other third countries
rather than in Europe itself.
So, those are the two things I really know
about data in Morocco that
hasn't been something.
Because my research was so
ethnographic among migrants
it wasn't something
that I encountered that much,
except sort of death by paperwork.
In especially the regularization process,
you had to submit a ton of papers.
You had to get a police report
and if you could find
your birth certificate
and all of those things.
And from my perspective, that
was a really effective way
to get more information
and better sense of
who migrants were, where they
are from, how many there were,
and just keep track of people.
So, I do see the regularization program
as also being a way to
keep that data, but again,
it went to the Ministry of Interior
and I don't know who
they're sharing it with.
And then Iman, "Have there
been moments in your field work
"where you were emotionally affected
"by what you've seen and heard?"
Yes.
(Leslie chuckles)
Yes, there definitely were.
But I would say one thing is
that the people that I was with
were so,
were just living their lives, right?
Western Central African
migrants had really hard times.
Things were often really bad,
but they were also.
(bird banging)
Oh my gosh! Sorry.
A bird just hit the window.
(Leslie chuckles)
Things were really bad, but they were also
not victims, right, in sort
of this unidimensional sense.
And so, being with them
and that sense of community
that was in those communities,
always lightened the load.
I mean, that's the best
way that I can say it.
And not just, I think,
for me, but also for them.
I think where I felt
heavier was when I came back
and was going back through my
field notes and writing it up
and I found writing...
I actually...
One, I found writing it up
really hard, but second,
I decided not to include
very many examples at all
for my field work.
So, a lot of my book manuscript
is drawing on just a few
anecdotes and unpacking them
one, because I don't wanna expose people
in that particular way,
especially when it's
sometimes at their hardest,
or their lowest spot.
And also because
I think there's been
plenty of documentation
about how hard it is
to be a Western Central
African migrant on the move.
And you don't need more
specificity from me on that.
So, that's kind of how I dealt with that.
I should also just add that
really the reason that
I came to this project,
it wasn't my original intention,
but having lived in Morocco,
I just met migrants.
And I was a member of the
Protestant Church in Morocco,
which became...
Really started diverting
a lot of its attention
to helping migrants
many of whom were
filling the congregations
across the country.
And so, for me, it was really just about
kind of looking around at where I'd been
and what was happening there in a country
that I love, I love it.
My first child was born in Morocco
and it's a place that's
really special to me.
But I wanted to think more about,
what these changes are that
I've witnessed over two decades
were really about
and also to locate a
lot of that culpability,
or responsibility in
Europe and more broadly
in white supremacy and the
legacies of colonialism
and racial capitalism.
So, that's kind of,
that's what brought me to this project.